hi we're here with Ryan Osborne and he
just set a world record what they did
was they flew up and down the Hudson
with helicopters projecting a 4k movie
on a humungous movie screen that doesn't
sound too easy so let's figure out how
they did it
hi there
my name's Ron Osborn and I'm here with
my team in New York to smash the world
record for the largest flying video
screen in the history of mankind in
conjunction with MTV and the VMAs bring
it on
the pilot who's flying the cinema screen
he's used to really high-risk
environments but then we get to the Huey
pilot who's playing the projector now
this guy we're talking Top Gun he flies
the crew next to live power line so that
they can literally step off from the
helicopter onto live power lines if I'm
going to trust anybody with my life I'm
going to trust in we take multiple rolls
of the fabric we stitch them together so
that we can allow for the bending and
torsion factors on the screen and we
also integrate like a safety line in the
front there's a special weight bag
system the air pockets are specific to
each size and shape banner when we got
here and did our calibration flights it
all paid off there are been
approximately 68 billion humans you've
ever lived on this planet and none of
them have ever done this
there's been no innovation in our
industry for like 30 years let's fill
that gap that's our mission do cool
in the sky if you imagine the Statue of
Liberty how high the Statue of Liberty
is our banner is that why it's about 250
foot wide so if you can see the Statue
of Liberty from like halfway up the
Hudson you'll see our banner miles it's
massive we've got about a hundred foot
of latitude we can fly closer or further
away and the system adjusts all the
rotation scale focus it just locks the
image onto the screen let's go we
actually stack the projectors one on top
of the other and that enables us to line
up the images so that they're all
projecting in the same area and we
triple our output what we're doing with
the aerial marketing and aerial
messaging is going to help our whole
industry and we're pulse I mean I'd have
to say millions of people are going to
see this I'd put 10 bucks on that
you